let's turn to Texas where investigators
are trying to figure out why a man armed
with an assault-style weapon went on a
chaotic and deadly shooting rampage in
the city of Odessa cell phone video
shows the suspect speeding down the
highway before slamming into patrol cars
in that city on Saturday officers
eventually shot and killed the gunman
during the standoff police say seven
people were killed ranging in age from
15 to 57 at least 22 others were hurt in
what is at least the 38th mass killing
this year that's a number that includes
incidents where more than three people
have been shot and killed our lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is in Odessa Texas David good morning
what are we learning this morning about
the shooter well there are two important
reports that we feel like you should
know about this morning one our
colleagues in Dallas report the gunman
had been fired from a trucking job here
in town right before the shooting
started there's another report this
morning from the Odessa newspaper which
says the gunman was fired a year ago
from another job for arguing and
threatening co-workers and the police
were notified in that case we are at the
movie theater here in Odessa and we're
here because this is where the rampage
ended but what police don't know when
they may never know is was the gunman
coming here to continue his rampage
[Music]
crowds of people took cover Saturday
afternoon terrorized by the gunfire that
erupted around them during the shooting
spree
police say the violence stretched more
than 10 miles across two different
cities in the heart of Texas oil country
Ethan by Iza was one of the people who
ran for safety we feared for our life so
it was the scariest moment of my life
the investigators say the rampage
started just after 3 p.m.
state troopers tried to pull over a
vehicle following reports that a person
was driving erratically the driver
opened fire with an assault-style rifle
hitting and wounding a trooper before
driving off for nearly two hours the
gunman led police on a high-speed chase
while firing at people randomly he
hijacked a male van at one point
killing 29 year-old Mary granado's who
was on her postal route working she was
screaming for help
Mary's twin sister Rosie was on the
phone with her when the gunmen attacked
did she ever say anything to you after
you heard the screaming police have
identified the shooter as 36 year old
Seth aider public records show he was
arrested in 2001 for two misdemeanors on
Sunday law enforcement was seen
searching a home in Odessa believed to
be connected to him the shooting
occurred less than a month after 22
people were killed at a Walmart in El
Paso Texas governor Greg Abbott we need
solutions that will keep guns out of the
hands of criminals like the killer here
in Odessa while also ensuring that we
save our Second Amendment rights the
governor says he does support
strengthening background checks to help
address gun violence but in recent mass
shootings here in Texas including Dallas
Sutherland Springs El Paso the gunman
obtained the weapon legally
so in that case stronger background
checks may not have prevented them from
getting the weapon Marlin you know what
we don't know is how the gunman in this
case got his weapon thank you very much
David